everything you write is gonna have some
personal
uh hook to you whether it's like
completely fantastical or not doesn't
matter it's the motion
do you believe everyone has their own
artistic voice
absolutely
i feel like
everyone has their own artistic voice i
don't think everyone
has that outlet to express their
artistic voice
and if they don't i think they should
and i feel very grateful that i have the
a career that i can and a space that i
can
and friends that i can with you know do
make movies or paint or play
music um
the coolest part about making movies is
all those things can be in the same
thing i hand painted the
the
titles to my dad dad you know the intro
and the whole end credits
oh wow um
my hand still hurts from it um but uh
but yeah i'm fortunate enough to have a
million of those you know and even like
my mom for example she's like a great
painter and
uh just
drawer and crafter and
uh i admire her for finding
an artistic outlet like that you know
because i know some people i mean it's
like you know everyone knows someone
who's super funny too
uh who's like not doing anything with it
you know whatever it's like oh you
should be a
no no you know what i mean
um
so yeah yeah i've definitely known
people like that yeah
so having gone to
different countries qatar being one of
them
and traveling
seeing that not everyone can express
their own voice
you think that makes you more grateful
for it i mean most people probably your
age haven't had that opportunity and
it's yeah i've never been
overseas so yeah
pretty cool that you got to see
different worlds absolutely if you
uh
feel like you can't voice your opinion
well
and you're living in a first world
country or
the united states i
urge you to check out other parts of the
world and
feel very grateful for that and but
free speech doesn't
come easy you know and it's
something you continually have to keep
your guard up for you know
i think uh
i think the world would would take away
would take away his free speech if there
was wasn't people out there
sticking their ground in art or
otherwise really you know
how does a writer gain confidence in
their voice
it's hard to gain confidence in your
voice when you're a writer
it's hard to write but let alone gain
confidence in it
it's impossible um
um
man i think just really
get good at taking notes you know and if
you're bad at taking notes just go get
notes like go get as many notes until
you don't feel as bad or you just feel
bad
you just feel dead inside and you're
like well i gotta keep writing and then
you'll write and then you'll start to
feel good about yourself again and then
you'll listen and you'll you'll know
when sometimes there's no notes on
certain aspects
of a script that you love if there's no
notes on it sometimes it's like amazing
sometimes it's the best part of your
movie you know
and um
at that point you'll know you finally
have confidence where it's like okay
i've been taking all these notes
and this part no one said a word about
nice that's good i believe it
oh that's interesting so it's not where
it would be where no one has an opinion
on it it's where it's like so great
leave it alone kind of thing
yeah i think so i think so i think when
you're reading a script and it doesn't
like ping you or like you get an alert
in your mind of like oh there's
something weird with that like that's
the best kind of writing where you're
like oh i'm like there or like i've
heard this so it's not weird to me um
just on a dialogue point of view or
you know there's there's crazy twists in
movies or there's pivotal moments for
sure that everyone will be like oh i
love that
but i think the most relatable moments
in a movie can be the quietest sometimes
and
even when watching it you could not know
it till years later for some movies you
know
what steps did you take to go from being
an actor to a screenwriter downloading
final draft
i'm not sure
hmm
yeah i think the
the cool thing
like if you're an actor out there the
coolest thing about it is that you're
forced to read scripts
uh or watch movies
and if you're not doing either of those
things you probably should there's
nothing else you could do but um
so
you you're familiar with
the language of movies or theater or
whatever it may be
and
you'll just know it i think i think the
actor friends i i have some multi
talented friends
who are actors and producers and writers
and
i'm not the only one out there but uh
who
their dialogue i can always
tell is just like one step above because
they've read so much stuff or they've
just
they're performing it in their mind and
they just you know it comes natural um
and and there are other writers out
there that do that who aren't actors and
i don't understand it
and i don't like them because
that's amazing but um
uh
[Music]
yeah the transition to becoming a
screenwriter from an actor uh i was
always doing it at the same time you
know whether it was just scribbling
notes or anything or
um just like
thinking of dialogue or telling stories
i was kind of afraid to make my dad at
first and and fabio was a good i guess
creative partner in this way to
pull me back in a weird way
um
funny enough fabio didn't know a lot of
the personal stuff that happened to me
in the movie until like halfway through
writing it um
and
on my side of things i didn't want to
put so much of my real life into a movie
to where i felt like i was like almost
cheating or it was just like a
documentary
um and now looking back at that i laugh
because it's like
everything you write is gonna have some
personal
uh hook to you whether it's like
completely fantastical or not doesn't
matter it's the motion
and um
and i think this was a great movie for
me to do as a as a first-time filmmaker
i think that stuff if you can just get
good at opening your own life and your
past experiences
there's going to be people out there who
are going to relate to it
for sure and
and i feel like to bring acting into
that as well
having performed so much
you can really
be attuned to that easier i know people
who don't want to talk about anything
about their own life you know but
just getting so many notes or getting
beat down or so many no's as an actor
you know you
you become
you know uh
familiar with it familiar with the
struggle for sure
did anyone say that to you don't use
your own or loosely based on your own
life as your first feature
wait on that i think fabio did
happen
he didn't say that but uh but it was
funny
uh
it was funny if fabio and i were talking
the other day we're just walking
somewhere and uh
and
fabio is like yeah it's crazy that so
many people talk about like authenticity
and like things have to be like directly
from your life like there's like jaws or
whatever and you know like space movies
and stuff
and we were like kind of going back and
forth on this i was like no it's like
the emotion the emotion you know of a
personal connection in whatever world
you're talking about
um and then uh and then fabio told me is
like well i mean who has enough
personal stories or uh instances in
their life to make a whole career out of
it and i was like well
i'll let you know i've got like eight
ideas you know of my own life um but
yeah i think when in doubt just like use
your own life and then uh
see what happens if you can't if you
can't
find anything you know it'll remind you
of something else